new evidence indicates the father and
son accused of murdering an unarmed
jogger offered to help deal with
potential trespassers in their Georgia
neighborhood CBS News has obtained a
copy of a text message a police officer
sent to a homeowner telling him to call
one of the suspects if he detected any
more action on a security camera Omar
Villafranca reports CBS News has
obtained new surveillance video related
to the ahmad armory case this video
taken on December 17th appears to show a
man leaving the house under construction
on February 11th a man was seen in this
same house that prompted a 9-1-1 call
from Travis McMichael McMichael would
eventually shoot our burry on February
23rd he said he spotted a man on the
property when I turned around and saw
him and backed up he reached into his
pocket and ran into the house I don't
know if he's armed or not but he looked
like he was acting like he worked
according to the property's owner Larry
English nothing was taken and he says
the man in the video may not have had
bad intentions in a statement English's
attorney says this young man may have
been coming into the property for water
there is a water source at the dock
behind the house as well as a source
near the front there are dozens of
surveillance videos showing people
frequently coming in and out of the
house including children a white couple
entered on the day of the shooting today
Gregory McMichaels attorney said there
is more to this case Greg McMichael
did not commit murder this is not some
sort of hate crime fueled by racism for
CBS this morning Saturday Omar
Villafranca Dallas